diese entdeckung ist ein echter
meilenstein in der astrophysik denn
bisher konnten wir nicht nachweisen
warum ein großteil der sterne leuchte
wort forschenden ist es jetzt gelungen
auch den zweiten fusionsprozess
nachzuweisen der unsere sonne antreibt
und das ist der fusionsprozess der im
universum eine viel größere rolle spielt
ein absoluter durchbruch für die sternen
forschung titk zum science und
wirtschaft gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst haben sich gekommen ist
wirklich verrückt wie wir tatsächlich
nicht wissen zum beispiel konnten wir
bisher nicht den wichtigsten
fusionsprozess im universum nachweisen
bei der sonne ist das anders da kennen
wir den hauptprozess und schon seit
langem versuchen wir menschen diese
kernfusion in der sonne nachzuahmen wir
berichten hier ja immer wieder über
zahlreiche projekte weltweit die das
spektakuläre ziel haben die kräfte der
sonne auch auf der erde zu entfesseln
denn natürliche kernfusion gibt es
bislang eben nur in sternen wie
beispielsweise unsere sonne diese stellt
tatsächlich einen gigantischen
fusionsreaktor da denn sie wandelt
kontinuierlich wasserstoff in helium und
dabei wird eine riesige menge energie
freigesetzt in der fachsprache ist vom
sogenannten wasserstoff brennen die rede
die große vision kernfusion auch auf der
erde als die neue primäre energiequelle
zu nutzen um erneuerbare energien zu
ergänzen für manche der weg schlechthin
aus der klimakrise doch wie genau
erzeugt die sonne
diese riesige menge an energie fachleute
gehen davon aus dass dies auf zwei
verschiedenen wegen funktioniert
hauptsächlich läuft innerhalb der sonne
wurde die sogenannte proton proton
reaktion ab die den großteil der
gesamten energie ergibt fachleute gehen
tatsächlich davon aus dass durch diese
eine fusionsreaktion rund 99 prozent der
sonnenenergie erzeugt wird für einfach
gesagt wird wasserstoff dabei zu helium
chemisch gesehen verschmelzen bei diesem
prozess zunächst zwei protonen zu einem
neu delhi um kern so wird ein neutrino
frei dann entsteht ein leichtes helium
isotop da der zuvor entstandene
wasserstoff mit einem weiteren proton
fusioniert erst dann geht es ans
eingemachte
nämlich dann wenn das endprodukt der
kernfusion entsteht das isotop helium 4
das kann über verschiedene reaktionswege
passieren ganz wichtig bei diesem
prozess wird masse in energie verwandelt
denn die atome verlieren masse bei
diesem prozess und energie wird
freigesetzt
forschende konnten in der vergangenheit
mit hilfe von detektoren auf der erde
frei gesetzte neutrinos aus dem haupt
fusionsprozess auf der sonne nachweisen
die durch ebendiese proton proton kette
entstanden sind
dies lässt die fachwelt mit ziemlicher
sicherheit sagen dass es sich dabei um
den hauptsächlichen fusions weg der
sonne handeln doch bereits vor 84 jahren
hatten zwei forscher einen weiteren
fusions weg der sonne vorhergesagt den
sogenannten c eno zyklus die beiden
physiker hans bethe und carl friedrich
von weizsäcker waren also schon damals
davon überzeugt in der sonne muss sich
ein weiterer fusions weg abspielen doch
erst jetzt ist es gelungen den ersten
experimentellen nachweis für diesen
zyklus in der sonne zu erbringen dabei
wurden charakteristische neutrinos die
bei genau diesem fusionsprozess
entstehen direkt beobachtet die
forschenden der sogenannten borek sino
kollaborationen haben solaren neutrinos
beobachtet die bei dem zeno zyklus
entstehen eine super spannende sache
denn hierbei handelt es sich um geister
teilchen die eigentlich gar nicht zu
beobachten sind denn das muss man sich
mal vorstellen milliarden dieser
neutrinos durchdringen in jeder sekunde
jeden quadratzentimeter der erde und das
ohne bemerkt zu werden sie sind
tatsächlich in der lage materie
ungehindert zu durchdringen menschen
häuser bäume einfach alles doch genau
das macht sie für die wissenschaft eben
auch zu idealen sondern um direkte und
unverfälschte informationen zu den
verhältnissen im zentrum der sonne zu
bekommen doch das einfangen der
neutrinos ist alles andere als leicht
denn gerade die neutrinos aus der 10
fusion sind vergleichsweise selten zudem
haben sie eine eher geringer energie die
maximal rund 1700 kilo elektronenvolt
beträgt deswegen besteht die gefahr sie
mit den neutrinos zu verwechseln die bei
radioaktiven zerfalls reaktionen
freigesetzt werden doch mit hilfe des
projekts ino observatoriums im größten
untergrund labor der welt in der nähe
roms haben fachleute diese
herausforderung jetzt gemeistert und
spannende daten über die neutrinos der
sonne gesammelt das berichten fachleute
im renommierten fachblatt nature boris
steht für brawn soll am 6
momentum bruno ist eben das experiment
einer internationalen forschergruppe bei
dem die neutrinos die aus der sonne
stamm erforscht werden sollen mit dabei
sind wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler aus den usa frankreich
russland italien und deutschland das
kernstück des bikes ino ist ein
kugelförmiger nylon ballon d or 280
tonnen einer speziellen zehntel ator
flüssigkeit enthält nicht nur die dicke
fettschicht des gran sasso gebirgsmassiv
schirmt ihn gegen die außenwelt ab
sondern auch seine stahlhülle und
mehrere flüssigkeits tanks wenn ein
neutrino zufällig mit einem elektron
kollidiert wird anteil seiner energie
auf das elektron übertragen und das
elektron bewegt sich und energie in form
eines winzigen lichtblitze wird frei
dafür notwendig aber sind riesige
detektoren bei milliarden neutrinos
treten dann wenige pro tag mit der
materie in wechselwirkung und können so
nachgewiesen werden hier entstehen also
lichtblitze wenn reaktionen mit seltenen
neutrinos stattfinden rund 2000 sensoren
delektieren die lichtteilchen denn auch
licht besteht aus teilchen aus den
photonen dazu die physikerin livia
nothofer die an dem experiment beteiligt
war
die von der neutrinos deponierte energie
ein wesentlicher parameter der analyse
ist mit der menge des detektierten
nichts korrigiert also steht damit in
einem festen verhältnis damit diese
empfindliche messungen überhaupt möglich
ist musste die natürliche radioaktivität
im kino gerät um mehrere größenordnung
auf ein noch nie dagewesenes niveau
verringert werden darüber hinaus wurde
der gesamte detector in den letzten
jahren therme stabilisiert was den
máximo phase 3 datensatz ermöglichte der
seit der 10 uhr entdeckung verwendet
wurden der nachweis der 10
trinos ist also eine echte premiere denn
auch wenn dieser fusion sweg theoretisch
bereits seit längerer zeit gut begründet
ist war es bisher nie gelungen in
experimentell zu beobachten um diesen
solaren zehen und neutrinos endlich auf
die spur zu kommen hat er das
forschungsteam die detector daten vom
sommer 2016 bis februar 2020 ganz genau
ins visier genommen und statistisch mit
sehr viel aufwand analysiert dieser
zyklus ist auch bekannt als beete
weizsäcker zyklus benannt eben nach den
beiden physiker hans bethe und carl
friedrich von weizsäcker hierbei
fusionieren wasserstoffkerne mit
schweren kern von stx
und kohlenstoff letztendlich und nach
mehreren zwischenschritten entsteht auch
hier aus jeweils vier wasserstoffkernen
ein helium 4 kernen und auch hier werden
neutrinos emittiert doch diese
unterscheiden sich bezüglich ihrer
energie von der denen der proton proton
kette zudem 10 uhr zyklus sagt die
wissenschaftlerin livia flutopfer er
wird ermöglicht durch das vorhandensein
von elementen schwerer als helium im
stern plasma die direkt an der
fusionsreaktion beteiligt sind
kohlenstoff stickstoff und sauerstoff
daher auch die bezeichnung zeno zyklus
sie leitet sich aus den chemischen
symbolen diese elemente haben die
fachleute gehen sogar davon aus dass
dieser zyklus im gesamten universum eine
entscheidende rolle spielt demnach
handelt es sich wohl um den primären
mechanismus für die stellare umwandlung
von wasserstoff in helium heißt also im
klartext auch wenn dieser prozess für
unsere sonne nur eine eher
untergeordnete rolle spielt ist dieser
fusions weg entscheiden für alle
massereichen sterne und die sonne hat im
vergleich zu vielen anderen sternen die
wesentlich schwerer und somit heißer
sind eine eher geringe masse der nun
geglückte nachweis dieser
fusionsreaktion ist also nicht nur ein
wichtiges puzzleteil hin zum
vollständigen verständnis der
fusionsprozesse in der sonne sondern
auch entscheidend für die erforschung
anderer sterne
denn hier ist der 10 der vorherrschende
weg um energie zu gewinnen laut
fachleuten haben wir hiermit also den
ersten nachweis dafür wie sterne die
schwerer sind als die sonne ihr leuchten
erzeugen doch nicht nur das diese
messungen könnten auch dabei helfen den
gehalt schwerer elemente in der sonne
und anderen stern zu bestimmen denn das
ausmaß der cdu fusion ist genau davon
abhängig der experimentelle nachweis
dieser solarzellen neutrinos sorgt
jedenfalls für große aufregung in der
fachwelt dazu schreibt der physiker
cabriolet begann der selbst nicht an der
studie teil
die bohrziele kollaboration präsentiert
ergebnisse die einen meilenstein der
neutrino physik darstellen diese
gewaltige errungenschaften bringt uns
näher an ein vollständiges verständnis
unserer sonne und der bildung
massereicher sterne durchbruch rekord
kernfusion in china erreicht da ist die
fusion wie auf der sonne tatsächlich für
eine rekordzeit gelungen also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren und zwar pixum
science and future mit bahnbrechenden
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen und
zwar dreimal in der woche bis dann
bleibt dran